used it heavily in the past. Would you
say that your position on the usage of
CF has changed or is there any or is
there another take? Why my stance has
never changed. People just like to
pretend that it has changed, but it has
never changed. If you want to talk about
people on the internet, be it Kiwi Farms
or some other place. I mean, I think you
should have a right to do that. They
want to get Kiwi Farms. Um but Kiwi
Farms basically ends up taking the fall
or getting the blame for literally
everything. Even though um even though a
lot of the stuff like the Uber Eatats
hacks, like the swattings and the
doxings, like there was that one
swatting that didn't even happen. the
person emailed me and told me that they
called the police. Um, I just don't
think it's right that like Kiwi Farms is
getting like the blame for every single
bad set on the internet. When you've
used it heavily in the past, would you
say that your position on the usage of
KF has changed or is there any or
there's another take? Why my stance has
never changed? People just like to
pretend that it has changed, but it has
never changed. Oh, whoops. So, here's
kind of what happens. Kiwi Farms is the
most visible site on the internet that
does harassment, but there's a lot of
other things that exist in the
background that are arguably responsible
for more. And none of those websites are
ever brought up because there's no glory
in chasing those websites. People want
to slay the dragon. They want to get
kiwi farms. But did all of the bad
things that have happened to her over
the past several months and blamed me
for her doxing. There is no proof or
evidence of any of this. I cannot.
Apparently Kebles was my first rolling.
Keep us rolling. I only be blamed for
Kiwi Farms creating a threat on her when
I had no involvement in it. Again, the
only
Wow. Oh my god. Interesting. Wow. Wow.
Why don't we maintain this logic now
with anything?
My god. You'd think it's like I I here
are unwell. Um but there's a website
called Kiwi Farms that generally is
supposed to just be like uh we talk
about or obsess over people that we deem
worthy of obsession. Um generally
they're not supposed to interfere too
much with them. That used to be the old
rules. But um for my life I guess K
Farms has decided that they're like a
full activist like we're going to do
every possible thing that we can to [__]
with this person and all the people
around him cuz that's just what they do.
You bring them into his circle and you
know he woos them and then you know oh
like all of this stuff the these are all
just like Kiwi Farms narratives that
just get like perpetuated. It's
narrative control and then it's how many
people around this person can we harass
or can we um dox or swat or whatever and
like that's just the goal for all of it.
Um just fine. I don't care. Um, but to
have like Kiwi Farms to be like a like
doxing swatting central that all these
other content creators, so all the
commentary community people, um, all of
the lefties, all of everybody else has
no problem and justical the people who
are skeptical of the Kiwi Farms angle.
Didn't you get a good chunk of your info
on Keles's from Kiwi Farms and
participate in the threads? Um, did I
post in Ke's thread? I feel like I
posted in my own thread a couple times
to to to search up, which worked
spectacularly. Um, but I most of the
research that I did for the Keel stuff
was research I ended up doing on my own.
Um, cuz a lot of it just came from
videos that she posted in conversations
that she had. So that narrative is
directly from Chis himself, by the way.
Yeah. Some people call me some people
want to call me a hypocrite because
they'll say, "I defended Kiwi Farms in
the past and now I'm anti- Kiwi Farms
because they're mean to me." Um, that's
the narrative that Kiwi Farms wants to
sell. And Joshua wants to sell that,
too, because he's literally like he's
trying to control the infighting in my
thread to direct people to be activists
against me, which is hilarious and not
even what like the farms is supposed to
be for, but okay. Another mentally ill
woman that Destiny had a long conflict
with was a woman named Anna. Just like
with Lav, Destiny also encouraged his
community to go to Anna's Kiwi Farms
thread and he encouraged them to post in
her thread. Oh, okay. Also, heads up,
this is my only non-media blackout time.
Okay, this is my only non- media
blackout time over media. Okay, somebody
on Kiwi Farms has made a thread of Anna.
So, if you are obsessed with Anna and
you want to talk about her all the time,
you chat her. You can actually go to
Kiwi Farms and you can go and post all
you want, read all you want. That go
there, post about it, talk about it.
People put a a lot of effort into
categorizing and archiving everything.
There you go. Okay. And in the thread
about Anna that Destiny encouraged his
fans to go message, they doxed Anna. Um,
you It's weird cuz you did the whole Mr.
Girl report review. I think you went
through theore section and then when
Destiny said, "I didn't do anything like
manipulative." Um, it literally says
that they were two days before he posted
her Kiwi Farms thing. And then he goes,
"Well, I didn't do that to like with
her." I did that to like get it out of
my community. And then when we go to the
DMs, like if you want to stay in this uh
Anna says, "What the is wrong with you,
dude? You just outed that Kiwi Farm
about me, dude. You are horrible." He
says, "I have a media blackout related
to your stuff, and I wanted to get
everyone Oh, I'm covering this up for
stream." Well, you guys aren't going to
see it. You'll see Connor's face. I have
a media blackout related to your stuff
and I wanted to everyone to get it out
before uh people were talking about it
incessantly over the next two weeks as
more and more people discovered it which
is like okay you are constantly the
second paragraph is where um when he
says oh I didn't do it to like make her
stop talking about I didn't do it to do
you are constantly talking about me on
your stream so I think it's fair for me
to bring it up you went as far to say I
I was abusive to you the last time you
mentioned me she says because you
threatened to leak my no news you
sociopath you literally ruined my life
you just doxed me on stream You put me
in danger. You're doing it. He says,
"You're doing it to yourself. You're
going to keep doing it to yourself. You
keep talking about me. Even if I say
something like, "I'm going to leak your
nudes if you talk about me anymore." Uh,
you're doing it to yourself, actually.
So, I would say this is very much, hey,
you have to stop what you're doing and I
will dox you and terrorize you and I'm
justified in doing that because you have
talked about me in somebody's military
career. No, it's all part of Kiwi Farms
is just basically a website where you
try to basically log all the information
about a person you might think is
relevant.
Yeah. No, they take like people who are
otherwise anonymous on the internet. Um,
no, they don't. Kiwi Farms doesn't care
about anonymous people. No, they don't.
They usually follow like many like like
online eelebs and that's what the whole
point of Kiwi Farms is milking cows that
are funny on the internet. You wouldn't
just like you wouldn't post like your
thread would get deleted for no
relevance. Like I've never been on you.
You haven't. If you think they just do
random people. I have. I have. I have
places like Kiwi Farms. It's kind of
you're kind of like beyond any normal
person at that point. Like guys, like
there's websites that are being taken
off the internet like for bad reasons.
Like really? What kind of sites? Okay.
Well, there's a site called Kiwi Farms.
Like what do they do there? Well, you
know, it's we it's like a bunch of
people that like obsess over laws on
like what's the law like? Okay. Well,
like if I explain this to you, it's
going to be really weird. It's like,
okay, well, I don't know if I even care
about this site. It sounds weird, you
know? Like that's the issue is that like
all of the things that are being
affected around it are kind of things at
the fringe, right? Like even for my
stuff like oh like I'm a big lefty, you
know, SJW and I got banned from Twitter
and it's not fair. And it's like really
damn. like what kind of stuff did you
tweet? Well, you know, I told a woman to
get by a shovel once, so I like more.
But um the issue that I have with Chudlo
Logic is that Chudlo Logic hosts the
Kiwi Farms equivalent of um on Discord,
which is Spicy Chat, which is basically
is another group of people that are
obsessed with me. Um and talk about my
[__] way too much, but it's just like a
crazy um it's like a Kiwi Farms Light
except it exists on Discord and it's
like a community that Chad Logic hosts
that I didn't want like any closess to.
Address logistical stuff is super
annoying all over his socials. He's
claiming that people are trying to kill
him because of you. Uh, he's lying.
Logistical like Queen. I'd kill him if I
could. I'd choke the house and do it.
Um, but not for I do want somebody to
logistical though or laugh or Mr. Girl
or Queen. Those people can all die. Uh,
uh, like people on Kiwi Farms are like,
"Has this guy ever been doxed before?"
Genuine question. I know nothing about
this guy. I know that he's just L cow,
but I've always found him so boring.
I've never seen any of his dramas. Like
it like if you even say something polite
about me. Um, there are people on this
thread who will and they say they're
like they're open about it. They're
like, "This guy's near destiny. I'm
going to dox this guy." And heads up,
this is my only non-media blackout time.
Okay, this is my only non- media black
time where immediately like this. Okay,
somebody on Kiwi Farms has made a thread
of Anna. So, if you are obsessed with
Anna and you want to talk about her all
the time, you chatter. You can actually
go to Kiwi Farms and you can go and post
all you want, read all you want, go
there, post about it, talk about it.
Actually, let's just do this because
this is going to be funny. There's like
a couple random things here, but hold
on. Did you see Did you see this? Yes,
he's been following the Splinter Discord
drama. Quan, he probably watched that
that video and he came over to my house
into my home recording studio and we
recorded this is he brings up recent
alleged issues found in Jtock's Discord
and Kelly's Discord footage from that.
Guy has millions of dollars by the way.
Millions of dollars watching Chris
Blood. What's going on? millions of
dollars and he is uh well just listen to
how he explains these things up too much
but just so like just as a quick example
of this um so one of the things that I
brought up before okay because um people
like I hate bringing up this name I
going to talk about it for two days now
u people so I bring up like on just
people's discord server right so what
they'll do is and what all these
communities do the reason why people
read these snark things is because other
side communities will take everything
from there and then they'll repost it
and they'll play stupid so I think like
just to go on his stream was like what
we don't do any of this what are you
talking about side discord servers what
who what do you even know one even does
anything, right? So, like Kelly, for
instance, who's now perman
by the way is not I somebody else must
have sped this up like making all these
side discords, right? I don't I don't
would I have claimed that there is no
like Splinter Discords for mine. I feel
like I wouldn't I feel like that's an
explicit problem. It's just like he's
just doing this. Yeah, it's like totally
dumb.
It's webbing. That's what it is. It's
like just guilt by association. Like
it's it's honestly like a little be like
he literally is just inventing things.
Like he actually is, he goes on, he's
just like actually maliciously inventing
a narrative out of nothing. Everybody
making a new general to wipe this
Discord because people keep getting
reported lol because they're just like
they do insane unhinged on all these
servers. And then they talk about this
is a DJ is reporting most of the people
in these servers by the way. Um and the
thing Kelly's banned for is actually
chastising other people for having
posted pictures of her in lingerie
because they didn't realize she was
underage at the time. I don't know her
exact age, but people were like, "Oh,
look at these pictures of people Kelly."
And she's like, "Actually, that little
like 10 pixel photo, this is uh I'm
underage there. You should delete that."
And her getting mad at somebody who
posted that is her getting banned from
the server apparently or getting her
Discord account perma banned cuz she was
like, "Hey, you did this before." By the
way, it wasn't for that picture being
posted. I don't think the person who
posted the picture got banned. It was
her saying it's up that you did that.
She got perma banned for that. None of,
by the way, not perma banned for any of
her comments on Destiny's girlfriend's.
just purely for her being like, "Hey,
it's weird that you posted pictures of
me when I was young." Like going through
um uh oh yeah, like me and Juice have
been doing a ton of bands on other
accounts cuz we don't know who these
people are. And the reason why they do
this is just so that they can repost and
talk all this insane every single day
for weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks
and weeks. This is talking about like
people who joined with Nina Nongrada.
You know Nina Nangrada, the person who's
like super skitso, super skitso on
Discord. She's she's deranged about
Yeah. Yes. Yes. Yes. That's um that's
who this is talking about. Somebody
Destiny knows who that is. But she's
like suspending like sus accounts. What
does he even say here? Like they do
insane unhinged on all these servers.
And then they talk about like going
through um uh Oh yeah, like me and J
have been doing a ton of bands on other
accounts cuz we don't know who these
people are. And the reason why they do
this is just so that they can repost and
talk all this insane every single day
for weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks
and weeks. what they So, I guess he's
trying to explain like why to people
like why he wouldn't have evidence of
any of this. But I'm curious why he
actually would be saying this. Like
obviously if he was going to make all
these assertions, he would already have
been shown the evidence, right? So, he
just should have that sitting in a
Discord DM somewhere. Now, now he seems
to be claiming that like, oh, I I won't
be able to find it cuz they've deleted
all of it. Yeah. Anyway, this is um not
This is literally I think Jub and Kelly
trying to get rid of those weird people
that came in before. do it enough so
that it gets filtered out through the
larger streamers and then you have your
jigs and your queens that report it for
like my stuff and then it gets picked up
by commentary people and that's kind of
like how the funnel works. Um, like
Kelly is talking about I don't really
want to post. I don't want to give links
to her. But like Kelly, so she's talking
about my girlfriend, how my girlfriend
deserves all the bad that Kelly is like
obsessed with saying about it. And then
Kelly's just talking about all of the
different gossip forums, um, including
Kiwi forms and other places where she's
reading and getting the information from
and it's like what the but she's saying
this in a side Discord server that she
doesn't know that I know exists and it
doesn't show up as evidently in the
Jessica server, although it's hard to
say because now every single person
there will delete all of their messages
at the end of every single day to keep
it like untraceable or whatever. So,
because DJs have been mass reporting my
discord, um, people probably do run like
redact or something now so they don't
get reported like mass reported over and
over again. Um, imagine deleting
messages. Who would do such a thing?
What a horrible thing to do. That's
crazy. Especially when you might have
especially when you might be accused of
wrongdoing because it wasn't those
messages. That'd be terrible. But also,
did you just see that he claimed that
like apparently the Kelly Discord is
like a secret Discord, a secret or
hidden discord that I definitely haven't
complained about and I definitely
haven't talked about in a 4hour long bod
[__] Discord exists that I haven't
like commissioned uh commissioned
artwork of like a little meme, like a
little uh seven layers of hell meme
about like all of the Splinter Discord
servers that exist and go on. I he's
like actually on so many levels of just
like conspiratorial I I can't tell if
he's like actually having like a
schizotypical meltdown or if he's just
lying blatantly blatantly he's just
trying I assume lying narratives about
how Discords are targeting him and so
that he can justify attacking them I
guess but which they've been doing for
over a month now but um that's just in
regards to my stuff personally but how
do people continue to take this argument
seriously that like everybody apparently
just stole the Kele's tech I I heard
Ethan do too. Like, oh, look, these
people reference Snark. They reference
Snark in the video. We don't have to
take it seriously. It's like, dude, just
contend with the information. Mhm. Yeah,
they just contend with the information.
It's also like it it works in regards to
this stuff as well. Um like the um the
the But now this is going to be I really
hope this is relevant. Is this I mean,
they were notorious for harassment
before. You say that, but I think a lot
of the harass I think that what happens
is so here's kind of what happens. Kiwi
Farms is the most visible site on the
internet that does harassment, but
there's a lot of other things that exist
in the background that are arguably
responsible for more. And none of those
websites are ever brought up because
there's no glory in chasing those
websites. People want to slay the
dragon. They want to get Kiwi Farms. But
this is when we did the whole we're not
going to talk about Doc Spin and how
they clearly harassed Keles. Yeah. um
farms basically ends up taking the we
mentioned this earlier today as well
fall or getting the blame for literally
everything even though um even though a
lot of the stuff like the Uber Eats
hacks like the swattings and the doxings
like there was that one well and the sad
thing is is like I would just love to
know when Destiny was swatted because I
know at least one of them was like that
was before any of this blew up, right?
Like Nathan was there like he talked
about it. Oh yeah, that was the Trump
one, right? It was the Trump one, I'm
pretty sure. And I'm wondering when the
other swattings were because apparently
he got swatted and he like absolutely
implied it was you or me or whoever
who's to blame for it. You actually we
actually bear a quantum responsibility
for everything wrong that has ever been
done to Destiny since he was a child.
Well, yeah. And like all of the doxing
of all of his friends happened before we
covered this stuff too as far as I know.
Right. Like it's not like his girlfriend
got doxed or something like uh or aid or
what whoever got doxed. It's not like
any of those people got doxed after the
coverage. It was all before. How how the
are we responsible for the docses that
happened before and the swattings that
happened before? Yep. Well, like I said,
it's quantum responsibility. It goes
back. It goes backwards. Happened. One
person emailed me and told me that they
called the police. Um I just don't think
it's right that like Kiwi Farms is
getting like the blame for every single
bad site on the internet. Now, if you
want to see the It's not right. Okay.
It's just not right that Kiwi Farms is
getting the blame for every other bad
site on the internet. Oh my god. No,
Jason Discord can get the blame for Kiwi
Farms, though emailed me and told me
that they called the police. I just
don't think it's right that like Kiwi
Farms is getting like the blame for
every single bad set on the internet.
Now, if you want to see that Kiwi Farm
should get nuked off the internet for
doxing, um fine, but like it has to be
for doxing like um it can't be made up
other you can't attribute. And like the
problem that I have too is that Wow.
Wow. This is uh I don't know. I I just I
hope at some point like some of the
completely people who are still in the
chat like the Douggee Chan guy, I hope
they'll look at this and just see this
person is like literally the biggest
hypocrite in the entire world. Like he
literally has no principles or anything
he stands for at all. But I Yeah. Well,
Seri, he talked about his position on KF
today. He did. I don't know if it's a
new thing or not thing. I don't know.
like these weird like anti-fan places
will pop up where they're these people
who are obsessed with like writing a
certain story or narrative about
somebody and then when they do it all
the other communities will pick the
information up and then it proliferates
from there basically but somehow all of
these side communities like pretend um
pretend that that's not what's happening
basically you know and it's just it's
yeah it's so to be like oh I can't
believe that Ethan would read this stuff
it's not healthy like well it's going to
show up in a song video probably in two
weeks anyways you know this is wow Ian
has to watch song yeah well well in the
video and he came over to my house and
to my home recording studio and We
recorded this is uh footage from that
and we talked for over 3 hours and I at
some point said I think we should
probably cut this off and we were having
a really in-depth conversation. A lot of
us ups and down. Can you give me a long
Kelly being banned from Discord? Um
there was some weird child thing that
popped up with justical server I think a
couple months ago. It was like after
they couldn't obsessively talk about my
stuff as much. Something weird happened
and a bunch of people in the server
either got banned or left the server. I
don't know exactly what happened. Um
wow. I don't is there was a child thing
that happened and and a really weird
thing happened after they couldn't talk
about him and everyone left the issue so
the issues right now Discord has if you
report people for child endangerment you
can basically report I I don't really
want to say it but basically like the
sensitivity on this thing is insane like
essentially if you've talked about kids
in any context whatsoever you can
probably be suspended from Discord um
there are huge videos of massive
Discords losing thousands of members to
this right and it's just a broadly known
issue and somebody took that and they've
applied it to like my discord where
there's like a script or a bot or
something that auto reports messages. So
yeah, we've had like a bunch of drop off
in activity because while somebody is
running this stuff and reporting all of
my then like it's going to people are
keep going to going to keep getting
reported and Kelly I think was one of
those accounts rip but I don't have
Kelly again her message being it's weird
that you guys shared pics of me when I
was underage or something like that that
she was perma banned for all the details
for that. I at some point said, "I think
we should probably cut this off." And
we're having a really in-depth
conversation, a lot of ups and downs.
And so, oh, and then he talks about Kiwi
Farms. I hand over all of the footage. I
just gave it to him. I was thinking I
wasn't going to be in the video cuz I
was thinking, how in the world content
in his style? How could he use anything
that we said in in that video because it
was so slow and, you know, in my
yammering way. I see a lot of people
argue that it's hypocritical for you to
criticize the use or mention of kiwi
farms when you've used it heavily in the
past. Would you say that your position
on the usage of KF has changed or is
there any is there another take? My
stance has never changed. People just
like to pretend that it has changed, but
it has never changed. Oh, whoops. one
swatting that didn't even happen. The
person emailed me and told me that they
up the internet for doxing. Um, fine.
But the dragon they want to get Kiwi
Farm most visible site on the internet.
I need that. I need the actual clip
again of him. Hold on. I'm going to line
this up. I'm going to line this up. I
mean, they were notorious for harassment
before. Lot of other things. None of
those websites are ever brought up
because there's no glory in chasing ends
up taking the fall or getting the blame.
They want to get Kiwi Farms. Um, but
Kiwi Farms basically ends up taking the
fall or getting the blame for literally
everything. Even though um even though a
lot of the stuff like the Uber Eats
hacks, like the swattings and the
doxings, like there was that one
swatting that didn't even happen. The
person emailed me and told me that they
called the police. Um I just don't think
it's right that like Kiwi Farms is
getting like the blame for every single
bad set on the internet. Now, if you
want to see that Kiwi Farm should get
nuked off the internet for doxing, I
missed the mark. Honestly, we've we've
totally up. But this is like an example
of one person who got banned, by the
way. Uh so next, Callum is going to say
he loves CPS. This is in regards to the
Ethan Klein drama. This person got timed
out from Discord. Got banned from
Discord for I can't tell how long.
Yeah, you broke the rules for child
safety. So there's And by the way, they
they I believe they um challenged this
and we're told no. Basically like no.
Like these are the level of messages
that are getting people kicked out and
it doesn't matter to anyone. It's uh try
talking to Discord. Discord doesn't
respond. There's no way to talk to
Discord. It's crazy. Sorry. He was
saying his uh opinion on calf has never
changed. Is there any is there another
take my stance has never changed. People
just like to pretend that it has changed
when it has never changed. If you want
to talk about people on the internet be
it kiwi farms or some other place. I
mean I think you should have a right to
do that and trying to tank websites like
that down by attacking like the
registars or attacking be like credit
companies. I don't think that's
necessarily I don't think that's a good
thing. I think if you want to make it
illegal then pass a law or try to do
something like that. Um but like my
stance on that has always been the same.
I still feel the same way about that.
But people are in this weird world where
they're like oh you think this person
should have a right to say this thing
that must mean that you agree with it
and you don't hate it. No. What? That's
like I can defend somebody's right to
say something. He just totally made up
entirely what his position was and still
think what they say. Dude, what is this
guy even talking about? You have a right
to say it, but also I think it would be
just you for it. Like that doesn't make
any sense. You idiot. It's nonsensical.
It's completely nonsensical. It's like
embarrassingly nonsensical. But people
still watch this guy. People are like,
"Yeah, this guy's really tapped. He's
tuned in. He's tapped in. He knows what
he's talking about." I It's like it
wasn't this bad before, right? Like Like
he This is the worst it's ever been,
right? He's never forced narratives
through that are
this square square peg in the round hole
level that's happening here. I have at
least I have to tell myself that to not
myself uh in a video game. Twitch in a
video game. Okay, hold on. I just need I
need to go back here. So when I handed
over all of the footage, I just gave it
to him. I was thinking I wasn't going to
be in the video because I was thinking
how in the world content in his style,
how could he use anything that he said
in in that video because it was so slow
and you know in my yammering way. I see
a lot of people argue that it's
hypocritical for you to criticize the
use or mention of kiwi farms when you've
used it heavily in the past. Would you
say that your position on the usage of
CF has changed or is there any there's
another chance has never changed. People
just like to pretend that it has changed
but it has never changed. If you want to
talk about people on the internet be it
Kiwi Farms or some other place I mean I
think you should have a right to do that
and trying to take websites like that
down by attacking like the registars or
attacking the the like credit companies.
I don't think that's necessarily Oh, I
this. Hold on. What is this? What is
this? On August 21st, she claimed that I
have actively facilitated all of the bad
things that have happened to her over
the past several months and blamed me
for her doxing. There is no proof or
evidence of any of this. I
cannot apparently debate. Keep us
rolling. Keep us rolling. I only be
blamed for Kiwi Farms creating a threat
on her when I had no involvement in it.
Again, the only
Wow. Oh my god. Interesting. Wow. Wow.
Why don't we maintain this logic now
with anything?
My god. You'd think it's like I I dude y
me personally me personally as a as a
liberal. I think I'm responsible for my
actions. You know, am I responsible for
some influence of, you know, what I send
out? Sure. Yeah. But fundamentally, my
actions and I should be held accountable
to what I've done. Now, apparently
there's a bunch of other people running
around that think you should be held
accountable for what? People you don't
even talk to. People you've got you have
no interaction with that you share a
Discord server with. Apparently, even
the ones people you don't, people that
are in when when you share a Discord
server with someone who posts on the
same website as someone else, you're
responsible for that third person's
actions. So, me personally, I think we
should be held accountable for our own
crimes. If Destiny's this a liberal,
then I mean that's that's his
prerogative, I guess. If he's not a
liberal, then remember when the worst
thing you could be was illiberal.
Remember? Yeah, I I remember they had to
cut Vos out. They had to cut Hassan out.
Hassan is like the worst person ever
because he's illiberal. FD Signifier is
the worst person ever because he's
illiberal. Vos, they hate the rule of
law. They hate the justice system. They
they hate democracy. They think you're
responsible for, you know, everything
your race does. It's you're responsible
for a date on the other side of the
world. You're a Jew, dude. I Oh, hold
on. I don't I I wonder if he only time I
posted her thread in my chat was to
counter the allegations that most of the
harassment she received came from my
community by proving the existence of a
Kiwi Farms thread. Oh, on her. Oh, so he
actually posted her Kiwi Farms thread. I
I don't know if I've ever done that,
actually. On August. What about you,
Queen? Have you posted his Kiwi Farms
thread somewhere? I honestly might. I've
got no idea, but it would have been a
long time ago if I did. I haven't
linked for sure. Probably Yeah, probably
before that, right? Probably post.
That's probably what I've linked.
Ah, dude. And not not any dog stuff. Not
any dog stuff to be totally clear. Just
a lengthy theory about how they had a
relationship long before he was leaking
that himself. But you've responded to
the allegations. How would you do that
without linking it? True, I guess. Um,
you mean clicking on it? I've already
said that I look at like documentary
evidence from there and I think it's
crazy they dox people but yeah I don't
need to share it around. I mean hold on
but even if I had like I assume I would
I don't even I think I broadly like
don't link there. I think I broadly like
um if I have like a piece of
information, I just take a screenshot.
But yeah, I so really all this po proves
is even if somebody had linked Kiwi
Farms, there'd need to be some intent
there, right? It seems to be what he's
saying that he's posted her thread, but
it was like essentially to say the
harassment is not coming from me, from
somewhere else. Seems like he's saying
this is not a moral wrong. I was I Dude,
I was looking for like the whole I
thought I was looking for the whole like
Kiwi Farm's been wrongly blamed. See,
what you've got to remember though is
that Destiny didn't write any of this.
So, these aren't really his positions.
Anyone that thinks Destiny was writing
manifestos is taking crazy pills. Bro,
the honestly the best explanation for
how the last one was is that Tom wrote
it. I've seen people say that. I don't
think that's true. I don't think that
was what Tom was saying. But but um the
I don't it's kind of crazy to me that
like basically every single bad thing
that's happening to her is blamed on
Kiwi Farms when there are other websites
that are working in the background that
are arguably doing more than Kiwi Farms
is. But crazy just now Kiwi Farm would
be totally responsible for all those
websites. Thanks Destiny.
Like and the the funny thing is is like
at least at least the docs was posted on
Kiwi Farms or something, right? Like at
least there are people talking about it
on Kiwi Farms. Mhm. At least there was
like probably like some pretty bad moral
lines crossed on gooey farms. In our
case, I'm not sure he can attach us to
like any of those things, like anything
like that. Like realistically, when when
you got given when Queen got given the
Lauren Southern DMs, he said, "Yeah, I
don't feel comfortable publishing this
actually and deleted a bunch of the the
guy posting it in his Discord." Was
like, "This is doesn't seem right." I I
literally said to the guy like I think
when the only thing I said to him was,
"If you're going to try posting this
again, get rid of her son's name." That
was was the like the only thing I said
to this guy was do do not post her son's
name. So would you say that you were you
know more or less more concerned about
Lawrence I wouldn't privacy I'm just
saying like I saying Destiny was well I
listen I like I said I don't want to sit
here and virtue signal grand cuz I truly
I don't care that much but it was just
that the first thing came to my mind was
you know immediately that's Lawrence
Southern's kid's name. I I can imagine
how [__] up it could be for Lauren
Southern's kid's name to get out because
of who Laurens Southern is. I wouldn't
want that to happen to a kid. You should
not release that. That that was my
immediate thought process. Now, you
could make a point about how Destiny
handed off those screenshots that
included that sensitive information to
not just Rose, but probably other people
and how that that's how it ended up
coming across my eyes. And apparently I
was engaging in more due diligence than
the Destiny. But yeah, I wouldn't I
wouldn't grandstand about something like
that personally. Yeah. Well, I
unfortunately as soon as I start
covering some Destiny, people start
hitting me with other Destiny. So,
quick. Sorry. I don't necessarily like
want to cover it that badly, but it is
pretty funny when I start getting
timestamps of all the he's been saying
for the past couple days. You're linking
me an immature album. Is this related to
something? I think you told me was
related to Ry, but hold on. What is this
exactly? This is This is people. Oh,
this is the responses to Destiny being
called a pest by Asmin Gold. At least he
has. He can't convince me Asmin Gold is
getting cheeks.
Yes. Okay. Asmin isn't afest because he
looks in the mirror and knows there's no
way it's going to happen. Uh, Destiny's
Bohemian lifestyle. Crazy. Calling
someone
afer who complains about video game
characters not being enough is peak
hypocrisy. In what way? Like, how can
you argue this guy's a virgin? actually
be as as uh lustful and and obje
objectifying as you want towards video
game characters. You know, you can you
can do that as much as you. It's a bit
different when it's people. It's a
little bit different when it's people.
It is. Does he even know what that
means? I think I think in his mind would
be his favorite. Okay. Wait, what's with
the title? Like that's the one
accusation that's distinctly true about
Destiny. He did a crime. In comparison,
manipulator and psychotic are far more
outrageous. What was the crime? shared
nudes to to a friend without that
someone's consent. To be clear, this
isn't merely an accusation. Destiny
admitted it. He did it. He just thought
it was okay for that particular someone.
Why do people lie? Okay, thanks. You So,
you weren't looking for information
here. You were trying to get into a
debate. Okay, thanks. From my
understanding, didn't she also do
something similar? Like, you already had
the information. You were looking for a
debate here. This is a liar. Sure. Yeah.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Also, this is like the
guy who's like responding is also lying.
Yep. Or at least Destiny believed so.
Destiny didn't believe so. I'm sorry.
That's It's clear he did not. So, uh,
bro, how rich is this? No pun intended.
Okay. Are we going through all these? At
least Destiny has How does your response
to this guy called me a pest? At least
Destiny has Oh, one second. Okay. Okay.
Um, we live in a world where morality
and taking accountability means all to
them. They got their pest. I got mines.
I give Oh, that was a that was one I saw
a lot. I don't know if you saw that. Uh,
this guy really like likes Trump but
calls destiny a past. It's just like
dude I People have broadly just gotten
rid of their morals. They're just like
anything the other anything the other
side does is allowed and Yeah. It's like
what weren't you criticizing Trump for
being
afra I'm I'm good without reading more
of this. I I wanted to watch whatever
the this other time stamp was really
quickly. Somebody said he comments on
the Lauren Southern affair. Oh, he
reached out, gave him the benefit of the
Destiny, answer my question, you coward.
What's your question? How can you
criticize Idubbbz for platforming Hassan
when you were implicitly promoting
Lauren Southern having have showing of
her docs on stream so you could have an
affair with her? Hey, know she wasn't
trying to have one with me and that's
why she had me show them. Could have
been the other way around. You can bring
have showing of her docs on stream so
you could have an affair with her. Hey,
know she wasn't trying to have one with
me and that's why she had me show them.
Could have been the other way around.
What? You can bring up any person that I
platformed on my stream for any reason.
The difference for all of these, whether
it's Lauren, whether it's Nick Fuentes,
whether it's Yo Mama, whether it's
literally anybody at all. Okay? The
difference is is I push back on that I
disagree with and that I should disagree
with on all of it. So you can say
whatever you want about anybody that
I've platform, but nobody who's ever
watched my content has ever come away
from me having a conversation with some
person think like, "Oh my god, I think
uh for the Nazis, right, Destiny must be
a full-on Nazi. That's crazy that he's a
full like nobody's ever thought this
ever. That's the difference. I I don't
know how hard it is for you to
understand that. It was a pretty simple
thing.